hi there today we'll look at bert ology
meets biology interpreting attention in
protein language models by Jessie big
Allie Madani love our Virginie kim jong
richard soccer and Nazneen fatima rajani
this paper is a investigative paper into
models that are trained on Biological
data specifically into Bert models
actually into a one specific bird model
that is trained on protein sequences now
it is trained to simply perform language
modeling on these protein sequences but
out of this language model you can then
inspect this bird model and read
important biological data of these
proteins higher-order data from the
attention heads of the bird model which
is pretty interesting basically means
that the information of these
higher-order functions is at some point
encoded in the structure of the language
of the protein sequence so we're going
to go through what this means and how
this comes about and what they did in
order to investigate I think this is a
pretty cool investigative work and
probably very promising for for future
research yeah as always if you like
content like this consider sharing it
out and leaving a like also tell me what
you think in the comments so biology
really quick for for people who maybe
never never heard this in your every
cell you have this thing called DNA
which basically is a an encoding of all
of your biological functions now usually
biological functions are realized
through proteins so DNA is basically a
building plan for all of your proteins
this happens in the following two steps
first there is this transcription step
where RNA is built this is basically a
copy of your DNA but is only singles
and as you can see right here and then
there is a translation step that finally
translates the RNA into the protein what
we'll end up is just a sequence of these
beads right here now these beads are
what are called amino acids so a protein
is simply a chain of these amino acids
there are 20 different amino acids and
the order of these amino acids in the
chain makes the function of the protein
now specifically we know about these
proteins that it seems to be very
important how they're three-dimensional
shape yes so a lot of these different
amino acids have different chemical
properties some are sort of I think
negatively charged some are neutral some
are acids and so on so they have very
different chemical properties so once
you build this protein and you kind of
release it into the cell it will curl up
into a three-dimensional structure so
this one might be you know doing
something like like this and sort of
form form a circle or something like
this just because the these proteins
here they kind of attract each other
maybe electrically and thus the protein
forms a circle and the function of the
protein is very much related to its
shape so if it is a circle it could
maybe you know trap something else in
here so you really have to think of
these things like kind of tools there
are proteins that cut other proteins and
they are really shaped sort of like like
a scissor that exactly fits these other
proteins such that you can effectively
cut them if so sometimes you can
substitute an amino acid for a different
amino acid like this here if it doesn't
change the shape very often you're in
yours you're find the protein function
isn't changed but if you change a
different amino acid that is sort of
vital to the shape and the shape changes
then your protein very often loses
function so
mutations in DNA sometimes lead to
mutations in protein not always because
there is some redundancy in this in this
translation step from RNA but if they do
lead to a different amino acid it
doesn't actually mean that the function
changes so there is sort of value in
analyzing the sequence of the structure
of proteins rather than the structure of
DNA of course it's also important to
analyze the structure of DNA but it is
also it is equally important to analyze
the structure of proteins because they
not all the information is in the
sequence not all the obvious information
is in the sequence so what does this
paper do this paper goes and takes a
model that has been trained on protein
data so if you look at this protein it
is simply a sequence of amino acids and
these amino acids they all have names I
think I have a table somewhere here yes
so these are the different amino acids
that exist and you can see a protein is
simply a a sequence of these names so
usually they're abbreviated by like a
three-letter abbreviation or just a one
letter abbreviation so a protein might
be a V M M V a G and so on and this is
just a string of text right so what I
can do is I can train a language model
on this a language model is simply a
model that takes a piece of text and
tells you what's the next piece of text
so what's the next letter what's the
next word in this case what's the next
amino acid and we can use tools from NLP
for that specifically we can train a
Bert model now Bert Bert works a bit
differently than a standard language
model Bert does what is called a little
masked language modeling so you would
take this string you would feed it into
a Bert model right here and I've made an
entire video on Bert if you want to
check the
out and what you'll do by inputting that
you'll mask out some of the tokens so
you maybe mask out this one mascot this
one and then you ask the model to
reconstruct those who say that here's an
M and here is an a without seeing them
so the model somehow has to learn from
the surrounding amino acids what this
amino acid could be right so it has to
reconstruct this sequence so the hope
here is in natural language is that bird
somehow learns something about language
itself by by being able to reconstruct
these things it has learned something
about language about which words appear
together and when it might even learn
very long distance relationships between
words just because it has to predict
those and the the idea carries over to
biology so it we might hope that a bird
trained on an amino acid sequence will
learn something about the about the
language of proteins about the amino
acid sequence and our goal here is to be
to ask can we somehow infer the 3d shape
of a protein which is the important part
from its sequence right here so given
its sequence can we infer the 3d shape
now as I understand it usually this has
to be done in like a simulation so you
would you would build this in a
simulator and then you do you do like
some sort of a a molecule simulation to
see how this ends up in a 3d shape you
could train a model to just predict the
3d shape but in this case we're just
interested what does the bird model
learn about the 3d shape while only ever
having been trained on predicting the
next or predicting the sequence of amino
acids so it's never been trained to to
look at the 3d shape and that's our goal
here so specifically we'll look at two
different things so here you can see
examples of proteins and their
high-level structure
so in in these proteins what you call
the primary structure is this sequence
of amino acid this is simply which amino
acid are in in which order there is a
thing called the secondary structures
and we often observe that spans of these
amino acids like substrings form these
what are called these helixes as you can
see here or these sheets I don't know
how there are strands in English we call
them sheets or I think these are the
alpha helixes and these are the beta
sheets and there is also a turns I think
this here might be a turn so there are
these kind of secondary structures and
then the tertiary structure is how these
this is still one this is one protein
this is one unbroken chain of amino acid
and you can see this here kind of forms
this double ring which would be its
tertiary structure very important for
predicting the tertiary structure is to
predict when two amino acids are close
to each other so if we have a chain
right here and the chain as we saw
before kind of turns and bends on itself
then these two amino acids here are very
close in close contact and to predict
which amino acids are in close contact
to each other it helps you determine the
the tertiary structure so that's a
consequence of it so we wonder does bird
know intrinsically which of these amino
acids are going to end up being in
contact with each other without ever
having been trained to do it the second
thing were interested in are binding
sites so here what you might not be able
to see but we made this example before
where this sort of forms a loop and then
I say can't wrap something here right
like another molecule and this is what
what we would call a binding site a
binding site is a one amino acid that
may be through the
structure of the surrounding amino acid
as well but also through its properties
and how it is exposed in 3d shape acts
as sort of a receptor for other
molecules it binds to other things it
can so think of your hemoglobin that
traps the the oxygen in your blood or
something like this the it is where a
chemical reaction or a a reaction with
something else will happen
that's a binding site and we are
interested does bird the bird that is
only trained on a language modeling
objective know which ones are the
binding sites because you know that
would be very interesting and not
something Bert was trained on by the way
a particularly liked Richard
soccer's tweet on this he I think he
tweeted out Oh Bert trained only on
language model can predict binding sites
and biological properties and formulated
it like it was you know like GPT three
was formulated like if we train on
Wikipedia our model can do math I
thought it was kind of a satire headline
if we train on Wikipedia our model can
predict biology and also it can tie your
shoes and cook your dinner yeah but so
it's trained on language modeling on
biological data and now that makes sense
so they're going to look at two
different things or actually more than
two different things but they formulate
this in an abstract way right here so
what they look at is the so called
properties property f and this property
F can be for example that a amino acid
is a binding site the property F can
also be that two amino acids are in
contact with each other so F always
takes I and J if in the case for example
where this is the contact property then
it simply is the indicator function for
when I and J are a
in contact and if it is a just a binding
site then I think we are looking at J at
the token level property we define to be
an indicator that returns 1 if the
property is present in token J ok so
whenever J is a binding site then that
holds so what we're looking at are these
attention heads invert if you don't know
Burt has an attention mechanism which
basically means from layer to layer each
token can attend to all other tokens so
here the amino acid sequence I've drawn
it twice and the next layer
representation of this amino acid we'll
be able to gather information from all
of the other amino acid through an
attention mechanism through a dynamic
routing algorithm I've made a video on
attention is all you need if you want to
find out more how this works now what
we're interested in is the strength of
these connections so the hypothesis is
if molecule here is one two three four
five and six
if molecule one and three are contact
sites then maybe we will find a layer
where this connection between 1 and 3 is
very strong right that would indicate
that there is a connection site or that
would indicate that Burt has learned
something about the connection sites ok
if we find this repeatedly so if we look
at many many proteins and whenever we
know that there is a contact between two
things and then we observe that the
corresponding attention is very high
then we can be pretty sure that Burt has
learned something about contact between
amino acids ok the same goes for binding
sites so if a if if for here is a
binding site and then all the
connections all the attention that the
entire layer
gets from four so all the information
routed away from four is very strong
that means all these other tokens are
paying special attention to the token
number four to this amino acid and if we
find that there's a big correlation with
this being a binding site then we can
reasonably conclude that Bert has
learned something about binding sites
all right so we're going to do a
correlative analysis for proteins where
we know the binding sites where we know
the contacts right we can analyze them
we can run simulations therefore we can
know them so we're going to look at this
quantity right here which is simply a
normalized quantity so we're going to
look at the attention in a given
attention head so as you know Bert has
many layers with many attention heads
and we're going to look at whether or
not this property is active and just
normalize it by the total attention in
that head so that we get some kind of a
percentage number that's the first task
we're basically going to look at how
does the attention correlate with these
properties and the second task we're
going to do is this probing task so a
probing task is like a linear probe in
like a classifier so what we're going to
do is we're going to take a layer right
here and even though it's an
intermediate layer we're simply going to
run it through a linear classifier and
then decide is this a binding site for
example or not is a given is a given
amino acid a binding site or not is a
given
pair a contact or not so this is kind of
a linear prop but this sort of takes a
back seat in this paper the analysis is
really on the attention heads and what
the attention heads learn and that's
already it they don't they take a pre
trained Bert model so there are these
Bert models that are already trained on
these protein databases and first they
look simply can we find attention
heads that correlate with a given amino
acid so here you see the attention to
the amino acid this is prolene I believe
and this is Fannie Lyla phenylalanine is
that the same in English yes
Fannie Lana Allah phenylalanine and
prolene right here so you can see that
the the plots here are there's almost no
attention pretty much throughout the
network that pays special attention to
the amino acid prolene
except this head right here seems to
have if you look at the scale over like
a 70% of attention always goes to
prolene in this particular head so this
is layer 1 head number 11
focuses 78% of its attention on prolene
now this is not that special if you
think about it because in in language
models as well in natural language
models you might want to think that you
have some mechanism in your neural
network that's especially specialized on
like a very particular word in the
language because that might just be a
often occurring a very particular word
for example in English maybe the is very
important or or the the word what these
these are like very indicative very
often occurring words so it is
reasonable to expect to find a an
attention head that pays a lot of
attention to these things especially
here where our vocabulary size is 20
instead of like 30,000 in natural
language and the same goes for this
phenylalanine
where you can see that in the layer in
the last layer and in the first layer
you have attention and also in the
protein you have in the last layer so
why does this make sense because what we
would expect from like single tokens
these are not interactions yet these are
not biological functions yet so we know
that in the lower layers of a neural net
work we have these kind of basic
features of basic feature extractors and
here these basic feature extractors
appear to be simply paying attention to
one specific token in the vocabulary a
lot okay so they kind of these heads
sort of specialize for single for single
amino acids and the same in the last
layer so in the very last layer the the
tasks of the very last layer is to
prepare for the classification tasks so
if you remember the bert bert-- model
you have layer layer layer layer and at
the end you'll have to predict which
ones are masked down here so at the end
you'll have to predict single amino
acids again so if there's a prolene
masked here you'll have to predict the
prolene so it also makes sense that the
last layers would very much specialized
to single tokens so this does make sense
now
our question is going to be do we find
the biological function where would you
expect them we would expect the let's
say the terror sheer it's already
secondary structures which are sort of
one level higher than the primary
structure we would expect to find them
maybe here and then we would expect to
find the tertiary structures maybe
somewhere here okay because these are
most highest level and then it goes it
goes back again or maybe it's like we
find the tertiary structures rather here
and here again and then in the middle
we'll find the the most high level the
tertiary structure certainly yeah the
blue secondary this drawing is getting
two to two weird but there there could
be multiple scenarios but that could fit
here but until now it sort of makes
sense so they do it in as an additional
investigation where as I told you
sometimes you can substitute an amino
acid and nothing really happens right
and in fact that this probably happens
in you right
you probably might have some mutation
that changed some amino acid and you
don't even realize because it's just
it's fine no no this so the biologists
can build these matrices of how much you
can substitute proteins with each other
so here you see this blosum62
substitution scores which are very I
guess very high if you can substitute to
protein to amino acids with each other
and the effect is negligible and it's
very low if it's the other way around
now this is interesting so far but you
compare this to this matrix right here
this is the attention similarity so what
we'll do is for each two amino acids we
take those two attention things those
two attention matrices and we'll
calculate the correlation between the
attention matrices and our hypothesis is
that the more correlated the attention
patterns are between the two amino acids
the more likely we are to substitute
them because as a direct result of our
language model our language model is is
it's reconstructing right these things
so our language model is going to treat
if in natural languages like a a synonym
right is our language model is going to
treat synonyms very similar to each
other because they're synonyms they can
be exchanged so a good language model
should learn that they are almost the
same and therefore the attention pattern
is going to be almost the same so a high
correlation we hypothesize is a means
that the function of the amino acids is
similar and therefore we can substitute
it easily so this here is the matrix of
the correlations between each two
attention patterns of these amino acid
and if you compare the two right here
they look extremely
Miller just have a have a look for a
little while and you'll see that the
patterns they do not match perfectly but
they are very very similar the dark
spots are in the same places the light
spots are in the same places so this
already makes a good case that the
language model here has learned
something about biology now what we want
to do is we want to investigate higher
order higher order functions so here
we're interested in these contact maps
right so how likely is it that two amino
acids are in contact and we'll look at
it through the lens of attention as we
did before so here you see percentage of
leads each head reach heads attention
that is aligned with contact maps
averaged over a data set suggesting that
had 12 4 is uniquely specialized for
contact predictions so look at this this
this head here is just spiking so
remember before we said our analysis is
whenever whenever we're basically
measuring the correlation of two things
being in contact because we know it from
our simulator from our data set the
correlation of that with an attention
connection being particularly strong and
will we find it in this attention head
right here so this layer 12 head number
4 will always peek out whenever two
things are in contact now you can see
that it's it's not like always it's like
25% of its attention but significantly
more than anything else right here in
fact if you group the things by this
attention you can build the following
plot so you can see right here
probability two amino acids are in
contact as a function of attention
between the amino acids in head 12 for
showing attention approximated perfectly
rated estimator which would be the
Greenline so here we simply for each for
each pairs two amino acids for each pair
of amino acid we plot we make a
histogram right here of what there are
not a histogram we plot the probability
if they have the attention weight point
nine we plot how likely is it that they
are in contact so this is this if we
just look at the data and we simply take
this attention weight as a measure as a
predictor of being in contact we get the
blue curve and the green curve would be
if we could perfectly predict from this
attention head what the probability of
contact would be and you can see that
the fit is fairly good you can't predict
with super high accuracy but the fit is
fairly good and you can see the general
trend that as the attention in this head
rises the probability of the two amino
acids being in contact with each other
also Rises so we can sort of confidently
say that Burt has learned something
about a higher level funk a higher level
biological structure just from the
language modeling objective how can we
interpret this this must somehow mean
that it is it is possible it is vital to
it is vital for reconstructing the
sequence from its surrounding so if we
delete this right here if if this if
these two are in contact in the 3d
structure that makes probably probably
means that this thing right here is a
very good predictor of what was here
right if we mask this out and were asked
to reconstruct which amino acid was
there then it probably helps to look at
its neighbors right it probably always
helps to look at one's neighbors a
especially also in natural language but
if these two are in contact they they
have very special
they have very special connection to
each other it's very you can basically
read out from this one which one this
was this is sort of like if you have a
sentence and you say who does I don't
know I can't come up with with one right
now
but if it's like da da da da da and then
there is a name like Marc and then that
I did it and then there is him right and
you would expect if I drop out okay
let's do it the other way around if I
drop out him then from the text right
here you can probably determine that it
is some sort of pronoun but then you go
back and you see oh it's Marc okay so
it's not like it's not like it or some
or or or she it's probably he or him
this is sort of the analogous structure
right here in biology the second thing
we're looking at is these these binding
sites now these are single properties of
of different amino acids and we're
simply looking at all the incoming or
sorry all the F all the other tokens
that focuses their attention why is this
important because these binding sites
are central to the structure of the
order to the function of the protein
right if this here is a binding site
then that's a very central important
point of the protein so a lot of these
other things are going to be determined
by what this binding site is this
binding site needs to have a very
sporadic particular function and
therefore probably needs to be a very
particular amino acid and the other
things here are sort of supporting this
binding site because they form the 3d
structure around it and so on so you
would expect
a lot of attention to be put on this
binding site and what do we find we find
that it's a bit more murky than before
so you can see that the attention is
kind of spread out percentage of eat
heads attention that focuses on binding
sites especially in the deeper layers
binding sites are targeted at much
higher frequency than would occur by
chance Head seven one has the highest
percent percentage with 34 percent so
also here you can see that it is spread
out but this is because multiple heads
are now focusing on these binding sites
because probably binding sites come in
different variations so you'll have lots
of heads specializing on attending to
binding sites and they say it is much
higher frequency than would occur by
chance and you can see here this head is
the highest with 34 percent of its
attention focused on binding sites you
can also see the general trend of the
attention being rather in the later
layers which we would expect from a
tertiary structure now yeah it would be
interesting here here you also see that
actually most of the things are in the
in the last layer which points to points
to rather maybe lower lower level
information because we reasoned before
about the last layer or I was just wrong
but also in a general trend you can see
that the attention is rather shifted
towards the later layers because this is
sort of a higher order function okay if
you look at this same F the same
calibration experiment you can see that
the picture' is not as clear there is a
general trend at the beginning but then
it sort of flattens out so you can sort
of differentiate the very probably not a
binding site from the somewhat probably
a binding site but it's not a perfectly
calibrated classifier and that might
just be because there are many things
specializing in different types of
binding sites so you can't just go to
one hand so this is just for this one
head you can't just go to that one and
expect that to classify all the binding
sites because you might want to be you
might want to combine all of the
high-ranking ones here to form a
classifier the last experiment they do
is these linear probes which where they
just go and they just build classifiers
from different parts of the network and
you can see right here that what is
predicted and how well they work so each
bar here is going to be the difference
of performance so this is differential
performance of diagnostic classifier by
layer sorted by task order in figure
eight each plot shows the change in
performance between the given layer and
the previous layer okay so a bar up
shows it's performing better than the
previous layer bar down shows it's
performing worse than the previous layer
so you see right here that the these are
these secondary structures right here
and you can see that there is a lot of
performance in the earlier layers right
here and sort of not that high
performance in the later layers whereas
for the tertiary structures the binding
side and the contact you can see that
there is a bit of performance on in
places but it sort of tends to be more
towards the middle certainly more at
towards the middle of at the end of the
network then the secondary structures
which sort of makes sense with our
hypothesis you can also see this here
where they show the percent of attention
focused as a function of layer and the
red is the center of mass and you can
see that as the the secondary structures
this their center of mass is at a lower
layer in general than the tertiary
functions all of this is not perfect of
course but it's still an open question I
guess whether or not it's not perfect
because we haven't built a strong enough
language model yet
do I want to say GPT for is now for
biology and not for language or is it
because there's really you need you you
really can't very well predict the these
things just from a language model I mean
you should technically all the
information is there but maybe the
language model objective as such isn't
able to capture that information so yeah
this this was the paper it's pretty
simple they have in the appendix they
have a lot of a lot of these additional
experiments or full experiments I
believe for all the amino acids and so
on and I invite you to check that out in
general I like this kind of work because
it's very applied it's and it can you
know tell us something about the nature
of both these language models and the
biological things that we that we care
about in biology okay I'm just talking
crap right now
thanks for being here I hope you enjoyed
it and bye bye